hey if you're if you're listening to
Evan Carmichael my friend Evan
Carmichael if you're listening to Evan
that means you're into success you're
into improving your life you're into
changing the game and making a
difference on the planet so if your
friend of Evans you're a friend of mine
naturally okay if you're looking for
ways to get attention keep feeding the
dream and take your business to the next
level then this video is for you
dude you don't get attention today you
have absolutely zero chance of being
successful money follows attention
period end a story from eight years old
like eight seven eight years old I've
just been feeding the beast for my
parents you know you made money you save
money you protected money and that was
good but but it's not the only solution
need motivation watch the top ten with
believe nation what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
into a drug rehab center at age 25 for
addiction to five years later becoming a
millionaire and today owning half a
billion dollars in real estate
investments he's Grant Cardone and
here's my take on his top ten rules to
success volume three enjoy
let's kick things off with rule number
one put yourself first
my dreams are first every day then my
wife then my kids I could take care of
my wife and my kids now would you agree
I abandoned this this is the fuel for
Who I am I abandon this dream and then I
end up I can't take care of them and
then I'm gonna tell them what it's
alright that you didn't win no it's not
alright if you don't win you need to win
how many of you need to win more okay if
you don't control your environment folks
somebody else is going to control your
environment you guys have run teams and
run organizations if you do not control
your environment someone else will
control your environment you are being
controlled in your environment right now
CNBC CNN MSNBC the parents the kids the
Twitter the Facebook the YouTube the
Google the snapchats are your
environment your friends in your
relatives your uncle's your aunts the
garbage dump called planet Earth that
you live on is mostly broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with me when I was 45 years old
my I'm gonna control my environment I'm
gonna take every penny I have all the
energy I have all the resources I have
and I'm gonna improve me if I got to go
broke in the process because I'm already
broke look if you're not fulfilled to
your if you're not reaching your full
potential every day you're broke right
now rule number two is get attention how
many of your parents told you this don't
get too much attention fly under the
radar don't toot your own horn be seen
and not heard dude you don't get
attention today you have absolutely zero
chance of being successful money follows
attention period in the story you guys
that don't have time for Facebook and
Twitter and snapchat and Instagram
you're like I ain't got time for all
that how many said that before you like
ain't got time for all that bullsh I'm
busy being broke I'm busy I'm busy
running my into the ground I'm busy I'm
busy freaking with a bunch of old lies
and old ideas
I'm busy paying for my house note for
the next 27 years stuck in one place and
I can't move two jobs rule number three
is keep feeding the dream I know
everybody's looking for hey when did
your life change look at changes
everyday so in and then and then you got
to add change on top of that how are you
gonna get to Mars right well you're
gonna build a ship you're gonna probably
blow up the first two or three of them
and then you're gonna stay focused on
the task get people around you that
don't make excuses get rid of people
that do and then you're gonna be like
hey we're going to Mars dude no matter
what it takes what it cost and you got
to keep feeding the dream you know and
so that's what I've done dude I like
from eight years old like eight seven
eight years old I've just been feeding
the beast and when I quit feeding the
beast of my dreams and fantasies when I
quit giving them energy what happened
was I started feeding other demons and
and my my life went downhill so by the
time I'm 25 I'm broke I'm wrecked I'm
spiritually bankrupt I'm physically
bankrupt I hate myself and then but I
didn't quit you know
and I just had to start rebuilding from
zero rule number four is don't make
excuses hey I was broke
do you understand I was broke when I was
twenty five dead broke I'm not talking
about financially broke let me tell you
something no I didn't have any money in
my pocket I didn't have any credit cards
nobody would give me credit okay didn't
have a driver's license
okay 1970 Ford Maverick had a 1970 Ford
Maverick no air no heat no door handles
the freakin floor was rusted okay I
lived in a 275 square foot apartment
maybe 300 square feet if you counted a
little step out of the front of the
front door but 275 a month and I was
late almost every month so don't tell me
about you money problems man okay don't
tell me about where you were born
don't tell me about you bad brakes don't
tell me about what your daddy did or
your uncle felt you up or something just
some kind of weird thing too you know
I'll ruin your head or your sister
abused you or whatever okay look we all
got problems you got to fix your
problems now you got to get your money
right so 25 years old I'm like I'm
getting my money right I'm done no more
excuses no more cry baby no more blame
I'm getting my freakin money right rule
number five my personal favorite study
success as I started studying people
that did more now people that didn't do
more not people that said do lists not
people that said hey don't be satisfied
or be satisfied not people that said
they'd be grateful for what you have I
started studying people that said and
had done more that you can do more
that's who I listen to today I listened
to the people aren't my friends in my
life the people I listen to the people I
talk to the people that I follow on
Facebook or YouTube or Instagram I don't
follow everybody I follow the people
that say you can do more dude I follow
the people that say I am doing more I
follow the people that are actually
doing something on this planet to make a
difference for the better you have to be
selective you have to give something up
okay you cannot listen to everybody to
every voice
- every person is quit or given up you
got to make a decision if you have that
little voice inside of you that says you
can do more you have to give attention
to that voice and you got to feed it
with those that support that idea that
you can do more rule number six work
super hard I remember my dad my dad died
when I was 10 years old he didn't have a
problem with work he said work is good
he said more work is better
he said lots of work is even better than
that and if you could get a whole bunch
of people working together you could
actually accomplish something now
fast-forward you know to somewhere in
the last 20 years work became an
addiction like oh my god your work
addict you're a compulsive work person
you're over achiever you have problems
in your life I'm like dude the only
problem I got in my life is that you
telling me work is a bad bad thing the
more I work the better I am the more I
get accomplished the happier I am the
more I work in a more accomplished the
better I feel about myself I'm not
trying to fill up a hole
I'm trying to get my reach my potential
rule number seven is expand okay check
this out 22 out of 28 million small
businesses in America have no employees
zero employees what kind of business is
that man I am the master and the slave I
am the prisoner the warden the jailhouse
the system you're stuck that's not a
business you cannot do the solopreneur
thing even though you see some guy on
Instagram rollin out with a Lambo okay
it's [ __ ] that's not a business a
business is people in a company anybody
know any major successful person that
didn't have a bunch of employees
anybody here know any great company that
had one employee one flow of income that
didn't use debt okay
caterpillar debt coca-cola dead Ford
Motor Company debt they had to use debt
you got to use debt to expand you can't
stay small and expect the world to know
you it's impossible rule number eight
aim for freedom
me successes is freedom like the end of
the day I want freedom my money's great
but money just gets this freedom right
so I see a lot of my peers in fact a
friend that I was doing business with a
couple years ago he said to me as I
grant your the freest guy no disgust
extremely wealthy or multi billions of
dollars he says you my friend are the
freest guy I know I said what do you
mean by that just came out of nowhere
you say what you we'd spent a lot of
time together he's like I've been with
you now for about a month and a half you
say what you want you do what you want
you know there's gonna be consequences
it's clear that you're consciously aware
that you're saying something that it's
gonna affect somebody he's like you're
not stupid
you know what you're doing I see you on
YouTube Facebook Twitter Instagram
snapchat he didn't even know what most
of these was he said he says I see you
say what you want as often as you want
willing to make mistakes she sees it too
right so she knows that we go into an
environments and she's gotten even used
to the fact that I'm gonna have my
opinion
I'm gonna go research things that other
people might find controversial I'm
gonna dig into things that people are
like saying no about well across the
line so for me it's about freedom it's
about can I go where I want can I do
business with you I want this is what
I've always wanted in my life I want to
go where I want I don't want to be fixed
in one spot I wanna be able to move rule
number nine go to the next level my
first 10 years of my life I remember
going being on one plane with my mom my
dad and my brothers and sisters we went
on one trip in ten years before that we
knew I never did I never been on a trip
we sat in coach and we flew to Los
Angeles and we went to Disneyland okay
and every time we were every time we
looked at something everything was too
expensive so and I was tripping out all
I knew was the people that had the money
had the control they decided when we
went to the Mickey Mouse pancakes shop
what rides we could be on and and you
know fast forward to today you know I
know I don't stand in line when I go to
Disneyland I'm like hey what do I have
to pay so I don't have to stand in line
my dad could have
done that too but he wasn't he didn't go
to the next level and and for him for my
parents you know you made money you
saved money you protected money and that
was good but but it's not the only
solution my dad stopped at save the
money and let's go on a trip you know
rather than hey you know what let's keep
building
let's keep growing let's be obsessed
with something monster not just enough
and and because my dad was satisfied
with enough he died at 52 I don't know
maybe he died at 52 the other way too
but when you scale out dude you can
actually live longer because you're not
doing all the work anymore and rule
number 10 the last one before the
bonuses set the right target what do you
not know about money you need to ask
yourself that what is it you don't know
about money you live on a planet that
has endless amounts of paper you have
plenty of sticky sticky note pads
everybody agree with that I mean how
many of your chart on legal pads or our
sticky notes are ear swabs or cotton
swabs you're not short on any of that
stuff everybody everybody has plenty of
that stuff except maybe the people in
Puerto Rico that by the way that's a
good example of what can happen to good
people bad things happen to good people
and money money solves some of those bad
things from happening to them would you
agree okay now if you didn't leave
Puerto Rico and you knew a cat5 storm
was coming or are most coming to Utah to
Florida or Harvey was coming to Houston
right or you live in Los Angeles and you
know there's earthquakes and you don't
have a plan
what is it you don't know like like
you're not stupid you're not dumb and
you're not lazy you're a bunch of
entrepreneurs in a room they want to do
something big you would not come to this
conference if you did not want to scale
your business the question was asked the
other night why do you want to scale you
all have to scale you have to scale for
this one reason right you need money you
need money okay why do I need money what
don't I know about money why are people
struggling with money you should ask
yourself these questions why are you
coming up short on money is that what
you know or what you don't know how many
of you know they're saying knowledge is
okay yeah how many of you agree with
that how many agree knowledge is power
so look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge could the wrong knowledge be
power over you right see what I'm saying
so like when you set your business up
how many of you set your business up you
know about the average entrepreneur solo
parliament or makes about 42,000 bucks a
year and the average American makes 58
this guy left a job to make less money
so he could say hey I'll work for myself
me and Gary Vaynerchuk had this
conversation he's like look somebody's
better off making 42 for themselves and
making 42 for somebody else I said dude
ain't nobody better off making 42 okay
so you see this is what you need to
understand the first thing you gotta you
gotta decide Nashawn says he doesn't
chase a number I chasing a number why
would you have a target on everything in
life and not have one on money every
athlete has a target right every
professional has a target every
department and every company every
division I have has a target no target
means what what is your target right if
I have no target I'm successful I will
hit the zero target
okay guys homeless out there hey begging
for food can you give me some food can
you give me some food I give him food
he's like no no I don't really want to
food I really want to just say it on the
sign bro you be on hundred just change
the ask but you gotta have a target you
got to have a target you're probably
thinking about that whole 10x thing that
we're talking about you see everywhere
but he's talking 10x how do I blow up
look check out this dude Evan Carmichael
he's finding out the things that the
most successful people in this planner
doing he's letting you know every day
how's it going guys yeah this bad team
right here okay
yeah yeah hey hey if you love having fun
give me a yeah baby that always makes
you smile okay Evan thanks for
everything you do brother be great god
bless 10x everything so first of all you
can always count on grant for some
amazing content he's always delivering
awesome value that helps entrepreneurs
but aspiring entrepreneurs and anybody
who has a dream and wants to achieve
more and work harder and go for their
goals I love it it's why we've been able
to do three series on him where
sometimes it's hard just to get a volume
one out this is version three for grant
my favorite rule from what he said in
this episode is rule number five study
success I think most of us have an
environment of mediocrity our parents
our friends our social media influences
the people who we surround ourselves
with are just doing okay they're just
they're just okay and they keep us where
we are and it's really difficult to
break free from the mold that you are in
and so you you maintain the same level
of thinking as the people that are
around you and that's why I've really
tried to study success is why I have
this channel it's why we're studying
grant today it's why these people are
behind on the wall it's why I consume
the content that I consume and try to
share with you guys as well because I
want to get to the next level I want to
break free of the chains that I have in
my current environment and continue to
build something better and so if
somebody else has done something that
you want to do you can go and do it too
it's been done you can do it if somebody
else has done it you can too you're just
not surrounding yourself with the right
people
to motivate you to uplift you to inspire
you and so I challenge you to design
that experience for yourself that every
day you're feeding knowledge and
inspiration motivation into your head
surrounding yourself with success
because if you're around success all day
long guess what some of it is gonna
bleed into you and you're gonna have
more success as well
so rule number five is my personal
favorite I love to know from you guys do
you agree is rule number five study
success the best rule of this video or
is the one that you like better let me
know leave it down the comments below
now I made this video because bez asked
me to if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you I'm going to profile next check
out the link in the description to the
request line that you can go and cast
your vote on and finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Michael from lead
the team net Michael thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my new book the
top 10 was a success I really appreciate
it man and thank you for sharing it on
your social channels too thank you thank
you thank you so much one final thank
you to you guys for watching I really
appreciate it I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're on where it is much love
I'll see you soon
you know so many people spend time and
put attention on the negative voices and
they ignore the fact that all of us also
have another voice in us that says hey
you know you can do something you know
you can do more than you're doing right
now problem is you can't figure out how
to do more that's all right you don't
need to figure out how to do more right
now you need examples of people that
have done more people that that have
made it and it broke out you want to
live on the beach in Miami you can okay
I don't care where you live today you
live in Nigeria you live in Mexico you
live in poverty you live in some urban
city you got a drug problem whatever
your problem is you can get out of that
problem I'm telling you what you've got
to keep you have to keep without this
being a lecture you have to keep your
attention on the glimmer keep your
attention on the glimmer this building
that I live in today the top floor is
thirty five million dollars second floor
is twenty five million dollars and every
other unit in the building is ten
million bucks I'm the poor guy in the
building not to get there to get there
if you want to get there
you got to keep giving attention to the
little voice that you can do more see
most people think success is a straight
line I'm gonna get out of high school
I'm gonna get a job and everything's
gonna be fine that's not how it plays
out folks okay this how it plays out guy
decides he wants something and the line
gets all squiggly see right now a guy
decides over the summer hey man I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get this job this
summer and I'm gonna make some money
this summer and then he gets distracted
by the first squiggly I don't know what
he's doing he's squiggling off because
he's not focused on his success he
squiggles you ever used this term
squiggle yeah man I'm doing a squiggle
you know I'm gonna go out and hang out
with the guys this weekend it's a
squiggle it's off path off purpose off
potential and so he ends up in a bunch
of loops over here most people get stuck
in loops I did it when I got out of high
school I was in a lot of trouble didn't
have any focus wasn't fulfilling my
potential was distracted didn't have a
coach didn't have an older brother
didn't have a father lost what am i
doing okay don't know where I'm going I
know I got this potential it's sitting
there inside of me it's a little candle
burning I know it's there I hadn't quite
put it out when I was 20 years old but
it was it was low any have you ever been
there what am i doing every day man why
am I getting up every day why am I going
to school I didn't even know what I was
going to school I was just going to
school I was just doing school I didn't
even want to go to school
see I'm squiggling around okay if you
persist and stay focused and surround
yourself with other people that persist
and stay focused
who knows maybe you'll come out the
other end some of you in there like hey
I could see you at 4 o'clock on Tuesday
right
and your customer says to you I'll see
you at 4 o'clock was visit let me look
at my calendar like like you're so busy
that is so old that is so old it is
dishonest it's dishonest man you want to
see me to sleep 4 o'clock I give you
Tuesday at 4 o'clock agree to it
done done I'll call you if something
changes if there's an earthquake between
now and next Tuesday Tuesday morning
there's a massive earthquake and I can't
be there you think everybody will
understand commit first figure the rest
out later close the deal right now
fill your calendar up your calendars got
the devil all over it white space on a
calendar and you will meet the devil you
don't need the - ok you go two or three
days without anything going on I'm gonna
just start having doubts here in health
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details